la reconversion des chantiers de la
norme est de la scène est en bonne voie
demain il y aura un premier contact
entre la mairie de la seyne est un
groupe franco britannique qui voulait
s'installer à la ciotat mais qui faute
de place est donc tournée vers la scène
et notamment vers l'association avenir
chantier de la norme aide ils veulent
entrer dans le fameux projet marot
police marais police une société
d'économie mixte dans la création sera
annoncée samedi prochain jean françois
joly bâle christian vennetier la fumée
du dernier baroud d'honneur de la cgt du
parti communiste dispersé c'était en
octobre 89
la vente aux enchères du matériel des
chantiers de la seigne a pu commencer 40
millions de francs un niveau que
personne n'espérait plus mais que faire
de cet espace à la scène face à la rade
militaire de toulon la tentation
touristique ne peut être que limitée et
avec 30 % de chômage s'impose à tous la
nécessité de créer des activités
porteuses d'emplois d'où l'idée du
projet marais police à dire vrai une
enveloppe plus qu'un contenu mais sur
lequel se portent un consensus général
ce qui est déjà beaucoup pour une ville
où les rivalités politiques et
syndicales ont été jadis exacerbée
jusqu'à la violence
nous constatons que malgré toutes les
manches les actions que nous avons
menées ensemble aussi pour essayer de
maintenir la construction navale à la
scène le résultat c'est que le chantier
naval s'est terminée pour la population
dans son ensemble
fiat ne prend en compte et nous faut
maintenant agir recréer pour une
reconversion de notre vie en général et
plus particulièrement sur le site du
chantier naval
le projet s'appuie d'un côté sur le port
et le centre-ville de l'autre sur
l'aiguillette 35 hectares moitié au
domaine maritime le long de la mer
moitié à la norme est coté ville avec un
thème imposé évident pour la thématique
du projet marie police est en fait la
rencontre de dut génie océanique et de
la protection de l'environnement
particulier la protection de
l'environnement du bassin méditerranéen
et ce projet doit s'articuler sur trois
espaces un espace urbain lahoun
nous trouvons actuellement qui serait
donc à la fois un centre de culture
scientifique un centre industriel en
tant que vitrine c'est à dire un centre
d'affaires un centre de formation
ensuite un pôle d'excellence
on pourrait cristalliser un laboratoire
de recherche et puis un espace
technologique un parc technologique avec
l'accueil d'industrie avec la caution de
la cité de la villette le syndicat mixte
qui sera créée le 7 avril proposera
trois secteurs d'activité urbain
recherche de pointe industrie de la mer
le projet marie police et issu d'une
identité une identité locale et
régionale qui articulé sur un tissu de
pme et pmi très fort en tant que
industries liées plus ou moins la mer
mais surtout delzenne des industries
innovantes mais également qu'ils
pourraient être en synergie avec les
laboratoires de recherche de la dcn
également par la présence de
l'université de la gare de toulon la
garde
ça joue tous se greffe sur ce concept
encore très floue une proposition
britannique de génie maritime et de
tourisme lourd une idée destinée
primitivement la ciotat et qu'il faudra
là aussi affiné pour faire fondre la
graisse sur la cité ces entreprises
considérable a coupé un grand espace au
coeur de la ville fermée était fermée
sur elle même et on est technique
inaccessible pour la ville
nous voulons donc ouvrir le centre ville
sur la rade de toulon donc à travers le
site du chantier naval aérer la spa
c'est l'aménagement
mais attention à ne pas prendre la proie
pour l'ombre à espérer des largesses des
créanciers qui hier encore demandé 67
millions pour céder les terrains de la
norme aide alors que le conseil général
n'en offre que la moitié et l'on sait
que l'expropriation est longue
événement demain soir à carpentras avec
la rouverture